eigentlich wurde ich vor allen Dingen
dass die Gesetze die da sind die er hart
genug sein könnten umgesetzt werden denn
das werden sie nicht eine dieser immer
wiederkehrenden Schlagzeilen Ulm ein
Mann missbraucht 129 mal ein Kind
zweieinhalb Jahre auf Bewährung und
genau das ist auch so das was oft in
unser Land passiert dass
Kinderschänder Kinder missbrauchen nicht
nur einfach Dutzend nach hundertfach und
eigentlich mit zweieinhalb Jahren auf
Bewährung freigelassen werden oft folgt
dann vielleicht sogar noch nach der
Taten den Mord hier liegt ja dann gibt's
natürlich höhere Strafen aber es wird
immer wieder und das merkt man toleriert
verharmlos und runter gespielt was das
ganze passiert ich war jetzt gerade in
Österreich weil dann gerade ein sehr
bekannter Schauspieler mit
58.000
digitalen Dateien von Kinderpornografie
erwischt wurde und Österreich ist noch
ein bisschen konservativer wie wir hier
und auch dort na ja hat man nicht so
richtig Einverständnis dafür und ich
sag's klar in Deutschland klar und
deutlich Deutschland und Österreich sind
Paradise für Kinder